in the ever evolving landscape of cyers
space where information is the currency
and data breaches post substantial
threats the role of cyber security has
become Paramount among the myate tools
employed by cyber Security Professionals
to safeguard digital environments one
category stands out for its ability to
intercept and analyze Network traffic
discreetly sniffers sniffers also known
as Network analyzers or packet sniffers
play a crucial role in identifying and
addressing potential vulnerabilities
within a network this exploration delts
into the realm of sniffers in cyber
security examining their functionality
applications and ethical considerations
as we navigate the intricate web of data
protection understanding how sniffers
operate becomes imperative for
fortifying the defenses that Shield our
digital assets from malicious intent and
just a quick info for you if you want to
upscale yourself master cyber security
skills and land your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learn's cohort of various cyber
Security Programs simply Larn offers
various certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
MIT I kpur EC Council and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
network security and over a dozen others
and that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire product and security
companies and academicians from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a cyber security role
as a fresher or move on to a higher
paying job role and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of interest and now let's get back
to the topic and we'll start with what
are sniffing attacks so in the realm of
cyber security sniffers act as
indispensable tools functioning as
virtual detectives to meticulously
observe and analyze Network traffic also
refer to as packet analyzers or network
analyzers sniffers capture and analyze
data packets transmitted across Networks
aing in troubleshooting security
analysis and optimization these
versatile tools identify issues like
congestion packet loss and security
threats offering valuable insights into
Network activities operating on both
wired and wireless networks and
supporting various protocols sniffers
provide a comprehensive view of digital
communication however their potential
for misuse such as intercepting
sensitive information underscores the
importance of ethical use adance to
regulations consent and legal Authority
is crucial to responsibly deploy
sniffers ensuring the enhancement of
network security in a legitimate and
secure manner so this was about what are
sniffing attacks now moving to
understanding these sniffing attacks so
sniffing attacks pose a significant
threat in the realm of cyber security
where attackers employ packet sniffers
to intercept and analyze sensitive data
traversing a network and these attacks
typically Target vulnerable points in a
network praying on unencrypted email
messages login credentials and financial
information the asyland in some
instances take the severity of their
tactics up a notch by utilizing
specialized sniffing attack tools and
packet sniffers this Advanced approach
allows them to not only intercept data
but also inject malicious code into
seemingly Banning data packets the
objective is clear to compromise the
security of the target's computer or
other devices paying the way for
unauthorized access and potential
exploitation in a sense sniffing attacks
highlight the critical importance of
securing networks encrypting sensitive
data and implementing robust cyber
security measures to twart the nefarious
efforts of those seeking to exploit
vulnerabilities in digital communication
so this was about sniffing attacks and
now we'll see how hackers intercept
packets and unveiling their tactics in
the realm of cyber security haers employ
various scanning techniques to intercept
packets traversing a network one
prevalent method involves the deployment
of a packet sniffer on a computer pther
to the Target Network functioning as a
proxy between the targeted devices and
the broader Network this tactic allows
attackers to clandestinely capture all
traffic forcing through the digital
veins another sophisticated approaches
ARP poisoning wherein attackers deceive
devices on the network into believing
they communicate with a different device
this manipulation grants hackers the
ability to intercept and scrutinize all
data exchanges transpiring between the
deceived devices so this is how hackers
intercept packets and now we'll explore
sniffing attack types So within the
Arsenal of sniffing attacks two primary
types emerge passive and active so first
we'll see the passive sniffing the
silent observer in passive sniffing
attacks hackers discreetly monitor
Network traffic without direct
interferences this subtle approach
proves advantageous for Gathering
intelligence about targets and the
nature of transmitted data such as Logan
credentials and email messages its
nonintrusive nature reduces the
likelihood of detection compared to more
conspicious attack methods so this was
about passive sniffing now moving to the
second type that is active sniffing so
active sniffing takes a more assertive
stance by involving the transmission of
speci espcially crafted packets to one
or more Targets this technique enables
attackers to bypass security measures
potentially allowing them to seize
sensitive information or even take
control of targeted systems the active
approach may also Encompass injecting
malicious Cod into systems and
amplifying the Arsenal of potential
threats and now moving to consequences
of a successful sniffing attack a
Triumph in a sniffing attack can unleash
a cascet of severe consequences on the
targets including clud the loss of
sensitive data that is the first one so
login credentials financial information
and confidential email messages may be
exposed and then comes injection of
malicious code attackers can infiltrate
Target systems gaining control or
assessing sensitive information and then
is the interruption of network traffic
the attack May disrupt communication and
impede overall Network performance and
then there is exposure of confidential
information Trade Secrets and propriety
data may be late be jeopardizing the
Integrity of an organization and then
comes reputation damage the compromise
Network can tarnish the reputation of
the effective organization and now
moving to preventing sniffing attacks so
mitigating the risk of sniffing attacks
requires a multifaceted approach the key
preventive measures include the number
one is encryption protocols implementing
encryption Shield sensitive data from
interception and then there is secure
network practices never transmitting
sensitive information over unencrypted
connections and then comes comprehensive
security softw ensuring all Network
connected devices are fortified with
antivirus and firewall protection and
then there is wireless network security
employing robust encryption like WBA or
web for safeguarding wireless networks
and then comes regular updates
consistently updating software and
devices with the latest security patches
and then comes Vigilant Network
monitoring remaining alert to network
traffic and promptly securing sensitive
information and then comes VPN
utilization employing virtual private
networks vpns when connecting to public
Wi-Fi networks and then comes continuous
monitoring regularly scrutinizing the
network for any unusual activity that
may signal an impending attack by
adopting these proactive measures
individuals and organizations can
bolster their defenses against the
stealthy threats posed by sniffing
attacks reinforcing the resilience of
their digital Landscapes and this was
all for this tutorial hope you guys
found it informative and helpful if you
like this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here